[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا طبعا التغطيه ما زالت
مستمره على العربيه منذ حصول الزلزال في
تركيا وروسيا وفي هذا اليوم السابع لهذا
الزلزال جهود جباره لن تعرف الكلل ولا
الملل في عمليات البحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاض فالدقائق وحتى الثواني هي ثمينه
جدا امام عقارب ساعه بدت تسير بالجهه
المعاكسه وكلما مر الوقت تتبدد الامال
وفرص النجاه تصبح قليله ارقام كبيره جدا
تلخص حصيله الزلزال الذي هز تركيا وسوريا
جغرافيا والعالم انسانيا وحجم كارثه
الزلزال لا مقياس لها بعد ان ضاعت بين
ركامه احلام بنيت في حقائب العمر وهدمت في
ثوان واصبحت القبور بالارقام لا بالاسماء
اما الان الكلمات تقف حائره فالصمت بات
هذا الموقف لحين سماعي نبض جديد من قاع
الارض يرسم فرحه جديده
كمان كانت الوسائل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يا عمي خليك صاحي يلا بسم الله
بسم الله الذي لا يضر مع اسمه ولا
ما فيها بسم
الله
على قيد الحياه كلمه يتجدد معها الامل من
تحت الركام
151 ساعه تحت الانقاض قضاها الشاب عبد
الله تحت ركام منزله المدمر فيها طاي
التركيه متمسكا بالحياه
خرج الى النور بعد سبعه ايام منظومه
الركام مانحا بارقه امل بدات بالتضاؤل مع
اقتراب مرور اسبوع على الكارثه
ومنها طائر الحزينه لم تتوقف قصص النجاه
والصمود
مزين اوف كلي السيده ذات الاربعه وستين
عاما لم يهزمها الزلزال وقوته خرجت من بين
الركام بعد 150 ساعه عثرت عليها فرق
الانقاذ وتم نقلها الى المستشفى واستضمه
وفرحه المنقذين امل ضئيل تجدد باحتماليه
العثور على المزيد من الناجين وبتجاهل
سباق الزمن
جهود فرق الانقاذ المتواصله تمكنت من
انتشار شخص عمره 50 عاما بعد اسبوع من
بقائه تحت الركام في انطاكيا اما الرضيع
ذو الاشهر السبعه فيها الطاي فقضى 140
ساعه تحت الركام قبل ان تنجح فرق اطفاء
تركيه من انقاذه وبين عمليه انقاذ واخرى
يقف العشرات من الاهالي الناجين بملامح
تعكس الما كبيرا يتجمهرون حول فرق الانقاذ
متشبسين بمعجزه العثور على احياء ملوك
الشيخ العربيه
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
مشاهدينا سنتابع ايضا هذه الصور من ديار
بكر
لمحاوله وهي مواصله للاعمال محاوله لانقاذ
احد الناجين حيث قيل منذ ساعات بانه يبدو
هناك ناجن متواجد تحت الانقاض في ديار بكر
ما زلنا نتابع يعني منذ ساعات بدات هذه
العمليه
محاولين ان يجدوا ناجا تحت انقاض هذه
هذه هذا الردم يعني وهذه الابنيه ما زالت
الاعمال في ديار بكر مستمره
وفي مختلف
الولايات المنكوبه هناك اكثر من 34 الف
عامل انقاذ يحاولون رفع الارقام وبنفس
الوقت ما زالت الامال بايجاد ناجين تحت
الانقاذ في هاتاي ايضا كان
معلومات بان هناك ناجل تحت الانقاض
بالاضافه الى شخصين معه ولكن لا معلومات
حولهم والان في ديار بكر ايضا هذه
العمليه ما زالت مستمره منذ ساعات في
محاوله لانقاذ حي ما زال تحت الانقاض
مشاهد الدمار طبعا كانت على مدار اسبوع من
كارثه الزلزال كانت قاسيه جدا قرن سوريه
سويت بالارض ومدن منكوبه تركيه تحتاج
لمليارات دولارات لان تقوم مجددا من خلال
محاكاه افتراضيه سنعود بالزمن للوراء
للحظه التي نادرا ما ترصدها الكاميرا في
التقرير التالي مع حنين الشويلي
في انقضاء الساعات الثقيله يصبح ما بعدها
اثقل
ويصبحوا هذا المشهد حلما وماضيا في اذهان
ووجداني من عاصر الدقيقه الفارقه او اقصر
هكذا كانت المدينه قبل الكارثه واللحظه
القادمه نادرا ما توثقها عدسه اللحظه
الاولى تنشا فيها بؤره زلزال تحت هذه
الارض لا التي اقف عليها بل في المركز على
بعد عشرات الكيلومترات وعمق ثلاثمائه
كيلومترا واكثر هنا لدرجه الزلزال الدور
الاكبر هذه هزه اولى بقوه 6 درجات او هزه
ارتداديه بقوه خمس درجات
لاحقت زلزالا يفوقها قوه لدرجه على الاقل
علميا الهزه اقل وطئه لكن هذا البيت
لم يذكر تداعى وانهار بحكم قدمه او سوء
معايير بناءه كارثه قد تحل بعشرات السكان
وربما بعض الماره ليسوا ارقاما بل الارواح
كانت امنه قبل ان تفاجئها الطبيعه
لكن امامك كارثه اكبر بالمقاييس والعواقب
ينظر الى دمار منزل او اثنين على انه
اضرار ضئيله وما سنوشك على محاكاته الان
نكبه عاشتها في 2010 كاليفورنيا الامريكيه
عام 89 تشيلي عامي 60 و 2010 وبقاع اخرى
وقف سكانها المحظوظون منهم امام خراب وترك
الالاف ضحايا تحت الالقاب
هذا ما حل بجنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا بعد
هذه اللحظه كل دقيقه بحساب وكل ثانيه
بنفسه هناك كانت غرفه النوم وهناك غرفه
المعيشه او المطبخ او الباب
كل ما كان اصبح ركاما يتسابق الوقت لرفعه
مع الموت والحياه الانقاذ والانقاذ
الامل
والالم
مع دخول الكارثه يومها السابع ان جون تعده
ممكنا على اصابع اليد لتصبح نجاه اي عالق
معجزه حرفيا عمليات بحث متواصله منذ اليوم
الاول ازدادت عزما مع مضي الايام لكنها
قلت املا
ساعه انتظار طويله احساسها اشبه بايام
لكنها ختمت اسبوعها الاول بالفعل فالزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا دخل يومه
السابع وكافه الضحايا في ميزان العالقين
باتت الراجحه حاليا متخطيه عتبه الثلاثين
الف قتيل
سبعه ايام قادمه وتزداد سوادا مع توقعات
بارتفاع اعداد القتلى لنحو الضعف لكن كيف
بدات
زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه ضرب على بعد 17
كيلومترا قرب غازي عنتاب في الساعه
الرابعه وسبعه عشره دقيقه بالتوقيت المحلي
تله زلزال اخر واكثر من 650 هزه ارتداديه
وفق مسؤولين اتراك حل مدمرا في عشر ولايات
تركيه وخمسه محافظات سوريه شملت حلب وادلب
عدد القتلى تخطى 7500 شخص في البلدين مع
استمرار معارك البحث عن ناجين واعلن
الرئيس التركي حاله الطوارئ بالولايات
العشر المتضرره لثلاثه اشهر لافتا الى
تضرر حوالي 13
مليون,500,000 شخص
و11000 مبنى
ثالث ايام الكارثه شهد تحذيرا من اغلاق
النافذه الذهبيه للعثور على ناجين مع وصول
عدد القتلى الى اكثر من 9000 قتيل
بعدها بيوم عداد الضحايا دقه عتبه العشرين
الفا مع استمرار عمليه البحث والانقاذ كما
سجل التاسع من فبراير وصول اول قافله
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر معبر باب
الهوى اجمالي عدد القتلى واصل ارتفاعه الى
اكثر من 22
بالاضافه 82 الف مصاب حقائق وقاده اردوغان
للاعتراف ببطء استجابه السلطات التركيه
للزلازل الجنوبي البلاد
مع دخول الكارثه يومها السادس اعلن مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري وقف عمليات الانقاذ
لتبدا عمليات انتشال الضحايا العالقين تحت
الانقاض اما في تركيا فتواصلت عمليات
البحث مسجله معجزه قليله
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ثلاثه وعشرين مليون شخص تاثروا
بالكارثه موت واصابات وتشريد جروح توازي
بعمقها شقوقا في مباني شبه صامده وطرقات
متقطعه
ومتابعه للاوضاع في اديمان ينضم الى محمود
شكر مفرد العربيه ومن غازي عنتاب مفرد
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي اهلا بكما
محمود ابدا معك الاوضاع في الديامان هل
مازلت في نفس الموقع حيث هناك عمليات رفع
انقاض
نعم نحن في هذه المدينه التي هي في اليوم
السادس واليوم السابع الورش تعمل على مدار
الساعه ولكن يبدو من خلال الجوله التي
قمنا بها منذ حوالي ساعه ومع ساعات الليل
الى ان اغلب الورش اطفات محركات اطفات
محركاتها في المدينه ايضا هذا ياخذنا الى
الى منطقه الى او الى جو اخر وهو بدء
عمليات البحث عن الجثث مع الاشاره الى انا
البحث عن نجينا لازال قائما ولكن بوتيره
خفيفه كنا مع ساعات الليل في الايام
الماضيه نشهد في هذا الحي والاحياء
المجاوره عمليات عمل لعشرات من الشاحنات
والحافلات والجرافات والحفارات والالات
الثقيله ولكن الصوره اختصرت مع هذه الليله
وايضا في الشوارع الرئيسيه على دخول وخروج
الشاحنات التي تنقل المساعدات الغذائيه
وايضا الشاحنات التي تنقل الردم وتنقل
التراب من مكان الى اخر هذه البنايه التي
هي وراءنا مباشره كان العمل بها على مدى
سبعه ايام منذ ساعتين انتهى عمال الانقاذ
بالوصول الى ام وطفرتها والى والد وثلاث
اطفاله اطفئوا المحركات وسالت فكان الجواب
الى انهم غدا سيبداون بعمليه رفع الانقاذ
للوصول الى الاساس بالاضافه الى ان حوالي
هذه البنايه عدد من البنيات القائمه ولكن
هي متصدعه جدا
ويخشون ان تنهار لذلك ايضا ستبدا عمليات
لرفع او لتهديم هذه البدايات
بالنسبه لغازه عنتاب عبد المحسن كيف هي
ايضا تبدو الاوضاع هناك ماذا عن عمليات
رفع الانقاض كان هناك منذ ساعات امال
بايجاد الطفل او شخص تحت الانقاض ماذا
لدينا من جديد
نعم بالفعل ميسون تم سماع صوت عصر هذا
اليوم في هذا الموقع تحديدا وتم تحديد
بانه الطفل بشكل مبدئي لذلك كانت عمليات
لحظات الصمت متتابعه ومتتاليه في هذا
الموقع فرق الانقاذ عملت على اكثر من
طريقه للوصول الى هذا الطفل او
انقاذه من هذا الموقع بالاضافه لذلك في
الطريق الى الوصول الى الطفل تم انتشال
عدد من الجثث سنتحدث عن ما يقارب
اربعه الى خمسه جثث اليوم تم انتشالها من
هذا الموقع
ووضعها مباشره في سيارات الموتى مباشره
لنقلها الى
المكان المخصص لها بالاضافه الى ذلك
عمليات الانقاذ يتم استخدام فيها تقنيات
حديثه من قبل الفريق الفريق الانقاذ
السعودي الذي يعمل في هذه المنطقه هم
يعملون باجهزه استشعار واجهزه تكسير
متقدمه بالاضافه الى اجهزه
متعدده
باجهزه ايضا تم وضعها لاستشعار
الهزات
والوضع في المباني
المجاوره تحدث عن المباني الايه للسقوط في
الجانب هذا هذا الموقع الذي يتم الحفر به
والبحث عن
البحث عن
عن مفقودين او حتى ناجين الفرص تتضاءل
بشكل كبير جدا ميسون على الحصول على ايه
ناجي او استخراجه من هذه المنطقه ولكن
الامل مع انه بسيط جدا ولكن يتم العمل على
ادنى مستويات
الاستشعار او يعني يقولون بانه لو كانت
نسبه الحصول على شخص ناجي اقل من واحد
بالمئه سنعمل للحصول او لانقاذه بشكل
مباشر هذا ما يقوله الفريق الانقاذ الذي
يعمل في هذه المنطقه ايضا هنالك بعض القصص
المحزنه في الحقيقه بعض العاملين من فرق
الانقاذ التركيه
واحد منهم كان يعمل في المنطقه
المحاذيه لهذا المنزل المنطقه الخلفيه
وكان يعمل ويحط الجميع على
العمل بكل
بكل جد
واجتهاد تبينوا لاحقا بان اخيه متواجد في
هذا المنزل فهو يريد الوصول الى اخيه في
هذا الموقع حقيقه قصص ماساويه كبيره جدا
ميسون وهي منتشره في كل زاويه تجد قصه
سواء
لاسر تنتظر ذويها او حتى
عاملين من فرق الانقاذ لديهم اقارب اما
ماتوا في مواقع ثانيه او يبحثون عنهم في
نفس الموقع الذي يبحثون عنه في ظل حاجه
كبيره جدا لفرق الانقاذ حاجه في كبيره جدا
لمساعدات الاغاثيه
لهؤلاء الاهالي البعض منهم خرج من منزله
تحدث عن اكثر من
2500 منزل في غازي عنتاب وحده قائله
للسقوط في تاريخ خرج الاهالي منها
بالاضافه ايضا الى الخوف والقلق الذي سرى
الى هؤلاء الاهالي وخرجوا جميعا من
منازلهم او الاغلب خرج من منازلها المدينه
خاليه جدا المدينه لا يتواجد فيها احد
يعني سالت احد السكان عن المدينه
وسبب هذا الفراغ الكبير جدا وقارنته بايام
كورونا وايام الحجر التي فرضت هنا قال بان
ذلك لم لم يعني لا يقارن بايام حجر كورونا
نعم نعم
بمختلف المناطق المنكوبه اشكرك عبد المحسن
الحربي موفد العربيه الى غازي عنتاب كما
اشكر زميلنا محمود شكر مفرد العربيه الى
اديمان
اعلنا مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه انطلاق الطائره الاغاثيه
السابعه الى تركيا من مطار الملك خالد
الدولي في الرياض وشمالة المساعدات
واطنانا من المواد الروائيه والمولدات
الكهربائيه نتابع
[موسيقى]
اعتقلت السلطات التركيه عشرات المقاولين
الذين يشتبه بمسؤوليتهم عن انهيار المباني
جراء الزلازل الذي بل الزلزال الذي وقع
الاسبوع الماضي وفي سياق متصل قال وزير
العدل انه جرى منع سفر اكثر من 150 شخصا
من المسؤولين عن تشييد مباني انهارت بفعل
الزلزال
لحظات كشفت مداها شاشه المباني في المناطق
المتضرره من زلزال تركيا والسلطات تحاول
احتواء الغضب الشعبي في هذه المناطق قوات
الامن نفذت حمله اعتقالات طالت عشرات
المقاولين والمهندسين واعلن وزير العدل
التركي بكير بوزداج انشاء مكتب للتحقيق في
جرائم الزلزال وما تبعه من وفيات واصابات
كما كشف الوزير عن اعتقال 62 من مقاولي
البناء فيما قالت وكاله انباء الاناضول ان
عدد المعتقلين تجاوز المئه في المقاطعات
العشره التي طالها الزلزال
تركيا سبق لها ان شددت قوانين البناء بعد
زلزال ازميت شمال غرب البلاد عام
1999 والذي قتل فيه 17 الف شخص المعايير
التي تم تحديثها عام 2018 تستلزم استخدام
هياكل مصنوعه من خرسانه عاليه الجوده
مدعمه بقضبان فولاذيه وعلى ان توزع
الاعمده لامتصاص تاثير الزلازل بشكل فعال
لكن رغم المعايير المفروضه قدمت السلطات
اعفاءات للمباني المنشاه دون شهادات
السلامه المطلوبه على ان يتم دفع رسوم
مقابل عدم الالتزام الاعفاءات هذه لقيه
انتقادات داخليه وحذر منتقدون من ان
التهاون في قوانين البناء قد يؤدي لكارثه
حال وقوع زلزال كبير في الجانب البحري
نقلت صحيفه حريات ديلين نيوز عن استاد
جيولوجيا بجامعه اسطنبول قوله ان اختيار
اماكن البناء جرى بشكل غير علمي مست جدا
بزلزال كايكور نيوزلنديه عام 2016 الذي
بلغت قوته 7.8 درجه وادى حينها لمقتل
شخصين واصابه 57 اخرين
من اسطنبول لا ينضم الى عبر الهاتف المحلل
السياسي اوكتايا المعزه استازيا الماز
اهلا بك معنا ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول
توقيف اكثر من 150 شخصا لهم علاقه بهذه
المباني التي دمرت
تحيه طيبه نعم تم توقيف هؤلاء المقابلين
على خلفيه التجاوزات الاتحاد التجاوزات في
شروط البناء وكذلك بتهمه المشاركه في
القطر
المتضررين
يعني هذه التجاوزات من المسؤول عنها هل
المقاول ام هناك مثلا اوراق ايضا يجب ان
تقدم من قبل هؤلاء المقاولين وان يوافق
عليها من قبل مؤسسات تابعه للحكومه او
مؤسسات رسميه
لكل التاكيد بكل التاكيد المسؤوليه لا
تتحملها فقط المقاولين هم يتحملون جزءا من
الماسونيه كذلك قبل ان
ياتي الدور للمقاولين هناك مسؤوليه للجهات
الاخرى الرسميه للبلديات هناك لكل يعني
هذه الامور نعم حكومه الحكومه وضعت قيودا
وشروطا
للانشاء هذه القيوط والشروط
ويجب تطابقها البلديات وفي لدى كل
البلديات اقسام للعمار وللانشاء وللخاس
يعني يعني من الممكن ان تكون البلديات هي
من قصرت يعني لم تراقب عمل هؤلاء
المقاولين
ليست فقط البلديات بدءا من الحكومه خاصه
الوزاره المعنيه وزاره الانشاء والاعمار
والبيئه الى البلديات وسائل البلديات
اقسام الاعمار والترخيص
الفنيين المشرفين على هذا على تلك المشاري
ومن يرخص هذه من جهه
للابنيه المرخصه بكل تاكيد هناك كانت
تساهل هناك كانت خلل والمشاكل والاهمال
والفساد هذه من جهه اخرى جزء من
الابنيه
المهتمه غير مرخصه اصلا غير مرخص اصلا
يعني تم انشاؤها وهكذا
ما هي
داعياتها يعني هذه التوقيفات المتكرره
هذه التوقيفات ما هي تداعياتها هل مثلا
نتوقع ان يكون هناك مثلا مواجهه مع
الحكومه هل ستؤثر على الرئيس اردوغان على
حكومته بعد هذا الزلزال وهذه الكارثه التي
حلت في بعض الولايات التركيه
يعني اذا كان الهدف من هو تطبيق القانون
والعقل يجب ان تحمل المسؤوليه على الجميع
وليست فقط على المقاولين كما قلت على
المهندسين المسؤولين على متراء الاعمار
والترخيص حتى
البلديات وهل نتوقع ان يحاسب وزراء مثلا
استاذ اوكتاي
نحن في النظام الديمقراطي نحن في دوله
الدستور والقانون يجب ان يحاسب الجميع
ولكن هل هذا واقعيا
ممكن لا اعتقد ماذا حصلت بعد زلزال مرمره
تم تقديم عدد من المقاولين واستمرت
المحاكمات الى ما لا نهايه وفي النهايه
سقطت معظم المحاكمات بالتقاطم وما الى ذلك
يعني برايك هذه التوقيفات هي فقط من اجل
امتصاص غضب الناس ولم تصل الى اي نتيجه
ربما ربما هناك محاوله لامتصاص الغضب
ستكون بكل تاكيد
المتضررين
والمنكوبين سيقدمون بكل تاكيد الى المحاكم
لمحاسبه جميع المسؤولين بما فيها طبعا
المقاولين لان معظم الابنيه خاصه على ابني
ابني للحكومه بقيت السينما بينما هدمت بعض
الحديثه
المنشاه من قبل بعض المقابلين
اللي كان لابد كان هناك خلل
والمشكله في انشاء هذه الابنيه والترخيص
طبعا لماذا كانت ترخيص وكان هناك عدم
المراقبه بشكل صريح من الممكن ان يكون هذا
الخلل متعمدا استاذ اوكتاي مثلا من يعني
هل الفساد هو وراء هذه المحنه التي حلت
بهذه الابنيه
هناك عوامل كثيره كبيره حقيقه اهمال ربما
هناك فساد ربما هناك تساؤل ربما عدم الوعي
وهناك
منفعه وما الى ذلك يا سيدتي الكريمه للاسف
الشديد
المجال
الانشاء والمقاولين او بالاحرى يعني
الاقوى الاقوى اللوبي في تركيا
والمقاولون في الحقيقه
واسفل الطريق الطريق للوصول الى المال
والسلطه
يعني انشاء شركه
المقاوله من هي الجهات التي تدعمهم استاذ
لماذا هم اقوياء الى هذا الحد المقابلين
في تركيا
باكثر من جميع انحاء من جميع
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني تركيا ضاحتها عدد
المقاولين الاكبر
من
هذا الاوروبي يعني اكثر خمسه الشركه في
تركيا تقريبا الشركات
المقاوله
هل تسمعني
كنت اسالك لماذا هم
اقوياء الى هذا الحد من هي الجهه التي
تدعمهم حتى يقوموا بهذه التجاوزات ولا
يحاسب ويكون بهذه القوه والسلطه التي
تتحدث عنها الان حضرتك
مجال المقاوله تدعم السياسه
والسياسه تدعم هذا المجال
شكرا لك من اسطنبول عبر الهاتف المحلل
السياسي اوكتاريال على المشاركه معنا
في وقت تتضارب فيه تصريحات وعن وصول
المساعدات وفتح المعابر الحدوديه بين
تركيا وسوريا الى الشمال السوري هناك ثلاث
معابر تعد شريان الحياه لاكثر من اربعه
ملايين شخص في شمال سوريا ابرزها معبر باب
الهوى الوحيد في شمال ادلب لعبور
المساعدات الانسانيه الى سوريا بموجب قرار
مجلس الامن الدولي وتسيطر عليه المعارضه
كما هناك معبر باب السلامه ويقع في منطقه
عزاز شمال حلب وتسيطر عليه فصائل المعارضه
السوريه واخيرا معبر الجرابلس الواقع في
ريف حلب والذي تسيطر عليه فصائل المعارضه
السوريه ايضا
طبعا
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
القطاع الصحي في مناطق شمال سوريا يشكو من
نقص المستلزمات الطبيه وضعف التمويل
لمواجهه اثار الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
المنطقه قبل نحو اسبوع نحن في مقبره
هاتايا الجديده التي استحدثت لدفن ضحايا
الزلزال المدمر هذه هي الصور من مقبره
هاتاي الجديده هذه الارقام على القبور
للموتى توضع بعد ان يتم تصوير الضحايا
ووضع ارقام واعطائهم ارقام معينه ومن بعد
ذلك يتم دفنها تاتي الجثث الى تلك الزاويه
تصور الجثث وبعد ذلك يتم دفنها بارقام
حتى يتسنى لمن لم يعرف مصير اقاربه ان
ياتي ويسال
[موسيقى]
حسيت انه الارص تحرك من تحته صارت صارت
الحجار وارتفع من حوالي والعماره صارت
تتحرك
صارت رقصه العرضة شوي رجعنا فزينا فزعانين
صار الحيطان تمر على الاولاد البنايات عم
تهبط على الارض
كنا بالبنايه الحيط على اخواتي بس انا
الحمد لله ما صعدني شيء انا واختي وطلعنا
من البدايه ما بعرف كيف
[موسيقى]
زلزال تركيا لم يتسبب فقط في تصدع المباني
وانما تسبب في تصدع جدار الثقه الذي يربط
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بالشارع فكلما مرت
الايام على الكارثه ووصلت فرق الانقاذ
عملها تزايدت اعداد ضحاياها وبالتالي زادت
سهام النقد الشعبي الموجهه لاردوغان
والحكومه وعلى راسها غياب سرعه الاستجابه
للزلزال العنيف وهي انتقادات لم يستسلم
اردوغان لها كعادته لكنه كذلك لم يستطع ان
ينكرها
بالطبع هناك ثغرات في عمليات الاستجابه
الاوليه من المستحيل الاستعداد لكارثه
كهذه يتعين على الناس الاستماع فقط الى
رسائل السلطات وتجاهل المحرضين رساله
اردوغان لمواطنه لم تمتص كل الغضب على ما
يبدو فذكريات الزلزال الذي وقع عام 1999
ما تزال حاضره في الاذهان بضحاياها الذين
قاربوا العشرين الفا وحتى اتهامات الفساد
التي كانت في ذلك التاريخ عادت لتتكرر
اليوم وبالاخص من قبل اهالي المنطقه
المنكوبه غازي عنتاب
شركه البناء القت بقطع خرسانيه لتراعي
شروط البناء الانشاءات لم تكن تحت اشراف
الدوله فمتى الكثير من الناس بسبب عدم
وجود رقبه
سلطت الضوء على قرارات بالعفو بحق نحو 75
الف مبنى سكني بنيت بالمخالفه لقواعد
انظمه الزلازل التي كانت الحكومه قد
اشترطتها والاخطر ان الحكومه كانت تنوي
ايضا اصدار عفو لعدد اخر من المباني قبل
الزلزال بايام وهناك رقم يحير الاتراك 36
مليار دولار جماعه الحكومه ضمن ضرائب فرضت
بعد زلزال عام 99 بهدف تهيئه البلاد لاي
زلزال قادم تقول المعارضه ان حجم الدمار
يظهر ان هذا المبلغ الضخم لم يصرف في محله
هناك تجربه اخرى تشكو منها المعارضه فبعد
كل حادثه تزيد فيها الانتقادات للحكومه
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تحدث مشكلات
في الدخول الى هذه المواقع لكن هذه المره
من حرم من استخدامها لم يكن المعارضون فقط
وانما بعض المحاصرين تحت الانقاض والذين
كانوا يحاولون بث رسائل عن انهم احياء
وارشاد فرق الانقاذ لمواقعهم عن السمان
العربيه
سقط احد عمال الانقاذ في هذا الموقع
وحصلت له اصابه في يده وايضا طلبوا طواقم
الاسعاف التي حضرت وكانت موجوده هنا اصلا
قاموا باسعافه بشكل او بلف ضماد وضع ضماد
في يده ومن ثم نقله الى مشفى قريب من
نوردا سيتم علاجه هناك ثم استكمل العمل
حيث توقف العمل لمده تقريبا عشر دقائق
لحين اسعافي ومن ثم استثمر العمل
[موسيقى]
اربعه بالليل للساعه 4:00 العصر يا
طالعوني
جيت على المستشفى وصار غسل مرتين
وهي الثالثه يمكن
[موسيقى]
كتير اصابات من الزلزال اصابات كانت شديده
للاسف المرضى اللي عم يطلعوا من تحت
الانقاط في عندهم كان هرس عضله هذا الامر
انا لعبت كتير علينا لانه نحن بالاساس ما
عنا هاي المستلزمات دارات التحالب الدموي
وهي دارات مكلفه
تعرض مشفى الاموم الدانه سامز
لتصدعات كبيره تم بفضل الله عز وجل اخلاء
المرضى والكادر بالسرعه القصوى للحفاظ على
سلامتهم
[موسيقى]
كاميرا العربيه توقف نحو 100 شاحنه محمله
بالوقود والمواد الاغاثيه ارسلت من مناطق
الاداره الكرديه ولا تزال عالقه في معبر
ام جلود الفاصل بين مناطق سيطره قسد
ومناطق الفصائل المواليه لتركيا التي ترفض
مرور هذه الشاحنات الى ادلب وريف حلب لا
تزالوا مساعدات الاداره الذاتيه والاهالي
لمن كوبي زلزال في مناطق المعارضه ونظام
عليقه هنا في المعابر هذه القافله تضم 30
صهريجا محمله بالوقود وهي الماده الاكثر
طلبا في عموم سوريا تجمدت هنا منذ ايام
تقول الاداره الذاتيه انها لا تضع اي شروط
لادخالها سوى سلامه السائقين والقافله
ذهبا وايابا بينما الحكومه المؤقته في
شمال غرب البلاد اشارت في بيان لها انها
تقبل مساعدات الاهالي والمنظمات بما معنى
انها ترفض مساعدات الاداره وقصد ليس ببعيد
من هنا علقت 100 شاحنه في معبر التائهه
تحمل الوقود والمواد الاغاثيه والانسانيه
كمساعدات لمناطق النظام يقول الاكراد ان
دمشق تطالب بحصه 80% منها كشرط لادخالها
وفيما يستمر الفرقاء في تسييس المساعدات
وعرقلتها تزداد معاناه السوريين الذين
وحدهم الزلزال من معبر ام جلود في مدينه
منبج شمال شرق سوريا جمعه كاش للعربيه
والحدث
من بلده حارم ينضم اليها الصحفي مسلم
السيد عيسى مسلم اهلا بك معنا كيف هي
الاوضاع في حارم وفي شمال السوري بشكل عام
وخاصه موضوع المساعدات اين وصل
مساء الخير يعني نحن في الساعات الاخيره
لانتهاء اليوم السابع من عمليات او بعد
هذه الكارثه زلزال مناطق شمال سوريا يعني
حتى اللحظه قام اليوم او بدا اليوم مع وجه
الصباح فرقه الدفاع المدني والانقاذ
باعاده او بالدخول بالمرحله الثانيه
لعمليات الانقاذ وهي التي قال انها
للبحث عن من تبقى من المفقوديه وجثث
القتلى بعد يوم من اعلانه المباشر انه لا
وجود لمؤشرات ان هناك احياء تحت هذه
الانقاض لكن بالمقابل العائلات التي
تواجدت في اماكن الزلزال ابلغت عن مئات
المفقودين حتى هذه اللحظه وبالتالي يتوجب
على فرق الانتفاع المدني والانقاذ
الاستمرار بعمليات البحث عن جثث المفقودين
وجثث القتل الذين قالوا تحت الانقاذ حتى
اللحظه ما تم اخراجه هو فقط يعني تقريبا
او او ما تم انقاذه من تحت الانقاذ سواء
على قيد الحياه او احياء لا يشكلون الا
نسبه ضئيله ممن هم مفقودين وبالتالي
الارقام مرجح مرجحه للزياده بشكل كبير
نتحدث عن
2170 تقريبا من القتلى وهذا الرقم غير
دقيق اطلاقا لان الارقام الحقيقيه ولم
تجمع على ارض الواقع نتيجه التشتت والفوضى
على ارض في ارض الميدان
تحدث اكثر من 5000
5000 مصاب
تحدثت في شمال غرب سوريا فقط اتحدث
الاحصائيات هنا فقط عن المناطق التابعه
للمعارضه
الارقام هي
2265 قتيل حتى اللحظه واكثر من 5000 مصاب
في هذه المنطقه فقط الارقام اتوقع ان تزيد
على الاقل بثلاثه اضعاف
وانا اتحدث عن القتلى لان ما رصدته في ارض
الواقع هناك مئات العوائل ابلغت بقوائم
وسجلت اسماء المفقودين لها لم يتم يعني
ايجادهم حتى هذه اللحظه سواء في
المستشفيات او في من ابلغ عن جثثهم ومن تم
دفنهم او من تحت لم يتم انتشاله حتى
الاحظه وبالتالي مئات الاشخاص مفقودين حتى
اللحظه في شمال غير سوريا تحت هذه المباني
المساعدات مسلم اين وصلت هل الشاحنات
المساعدات تستطيع الوصول الى هذه المناطق
اعطينا تفاصيل لو سمحت
اليوم كان يعني افضل نسبيا من الايام
القليله الماضيه بدات الشاحنات في علم
بالدخول وثقنا حتى اللحظه قرابه الخمسه
وستين شاحنه دخلت عبر المعابر الحدوديه
وهي التي تفصل بين سوريا وتركيا ان اتحدث
عن مناطق المعارضه ثلاث معابر هي معبر باب
الهوى معبر باب السلامه ومعبر الحمام
القريب من جنديرس هذه المعابر استقبلت
حوالي 65 شاحنه منذ ليله الامس وحتى اليوم
هذه الشاحنات تدخل مباشره الى افراغها
للشاحنات السوريه التابعه للمؤسسات
والمنظمات المحليه ثم يعني تتوجه الى
الاماكن المتضرره بشكل مباشر الى مراكز
الايواء يتم توزيعها لكن قالت المنظمات ان
ما دخل حتى اللحظه يشكل واحد بالمئه
تقريبا فقط من الاحتياج الانساني يبدو ان
دائره الاحتياجات الانسانيه تتوسع بشكل
خطير اول نتيجه زياده عدد المفقودين
وزياده عدد ايضا المهجرين والمخاطر
خلال ساعات القادمه لاننا نتحدث عن درجات
حراره منخفضه جدا ناقص اثنان تقريبا هنا
في هذه المنطقه وما تزال الاف العوائل
تسترش الطرقات الساحات العامه وغيرها وهي
بحاجه الى اغاثه عاجله متعلقه اولا بمواد
التاثير او غيرها حتى تنتهي هذه الموجه
ويتم السيطره فقط على مرحله الطوارئ يتم
يعني انقاذ ما تبقى من
الاهالي تحت شكرا لك مسلم السيد عيسى كنت
معي من حارم على كل هذه التفاصيل
والمعلومات
[موسيقى]
غير قوه الزلزال هائله تمت عوامل اخرى كان
لها دور في ارتفاع اعداد ضحايا فالزلزال
وحده لا يقتل الناس انما ايضا مخالفات
البناء نتابع
شواهد قبور ضحايا الزلزال باتت تميز
بالارقام بدلا من الاسماء
فالتعرف على هويه الضحايا لم يعد متاحا
لذويهم امام حجم الكارثه
[موسيقى]
قوه الزلزال عند سبع درجات لم تسجل في
التاريخ الا 20 مره كان اخرها في نيبال
بقوه سبع درجات فاصل ثمانيه عام 2015
حينها اودى بتسعه الاف شخص
هناك عوامل اخرى غير حركه الطبقات
التكتونيه كانت وراء وقوع هذه الاعداد
الضخمه
[موسيقى]
مباغته الزلزال في الرابعه صباحا جعلت
النائمون يجدون انفسهم عانقين عندما
انهارت منازلهم فضلا عن تاخر استجابه اطقم
الاغاثه في هذه الساعه المبكره
10 ولايات ضربها الزلزال شتت جهود عمليات
الانقاذ من حيث تحديد اولويه المناطق
الاكثر احتياجا
فالساعات الذهبيه هي الاولى في عمليات
الانقاذ لكنها جاءت متاخره بفعل انهيارات
الطرق المؤديه الى المواقع المتاثره ليصل
بعضهم في اليوم الثاني والثالث الى تلك
الوجهات
مخالفه متعهد البناء لمعايير مقاومه
الزلزال التي تفرضها التشريعات في تركيا
على وضع زلزال عام 1999
سيدي الحديدي العربيه
تسببت الامكانيات الشحيحه لمواجهه الزلزال
في شمال غرب سوريا المنكوب باضافه كارثه
الى الكارثه القصص المؤلمه المرتبطه
بالزلزال كانت كثيره اما قصص الفرح فهي
نادره هذه واحده منها
[موسيقى]
يضل الرجل طفلا حتى تموت امه فاذا ماتت
شاخ فجاه
اختلفوا كثيرا حول من قال ذلك ولكن
الاختلاف حول صدق المعنى
ادلب بعد 36 ساعه من بقاء امه تحت الانقاذ
ابلغوه انها فارقت الحياه ليتحول الرجل
الذي خالط الشيب لحيته الى طفل يواجه
شعورا يطمي لاول مره الله اكبر
ولكن بعد ذلك بساعات تنقلب حياته مره اخرى
هذه المره للافضل الام تم انقاذها وهي على
قيد الحياه ليحصل على فرصه اخرى فرصه لن
يترك فيها ابدا السيده التي استقبلته
حينما ابصر النور لاول مره
[موسيقى]
والله كلنا بخير
يخاف سكان المناطق المنكوبه من العوده الى
منازلهم التي لم يسقطها الزلزال بسبب تصدع
المباني الامر الذي جعلها ايل للسقوط
بسهوله
ابنيه قائمه لكن الى متى دمر زلزال سوريا
وتركيا الاف الابنيه واستوت بالارض لكن
القائم منها ايضا تصدع وبات ايلا للسقوط
في اي لحظه
لم يتشرد فقط من فقدوا منازلهم بل ايضا
اولئك الخائفون من العوده الى ابنيه
انتشرت في دعاماتها الشروخ وتتمايل من اي
هزه ارتداديه
اصلها من سكان مدينه انطاكيا والتي تضررت
بشكل كبير من الزلزال لجات مع زوجها
واطفالها الى مبنى في حديقه ورغم ان
منزلها لم يسقط الا انها تريد المغادره
والاستقرار في مكان امن
نريد المغادره فقدت اربعه من افراد عائلتي
نجا ثلاثه اشقاء فقط نحن عالقنا هنا ولا
يوجد احد لا اعرف كيف سنغادر
رعب وحزن لم يقتصر على من فقدوا احبتهم
ومسكنهم بل حاله عامه سكنت قلوبك كل من
شهد الكارثه التي هزت المنطقه على نطاق
واسع ديسمبر
اعتقدنا في البدايه انه تم تدمير ثلاث او
خمسه مباني فقط وعندما اشرقت الشمس ادركنا
حجم الزلزال وعندها فقط فهمنا الموقف
خياران لا ثالث لهما امام السكان المناطق
المنكوبه اما المغادره بحثا عن مامن من
الخطر المستمر منذ اسبوع او البقاء بين
الانقاض بانتظار منازل لن تعود على الاقل
في المدى القريب
وكلاهما فيه تشرد ينتظر المنكوبين حتى
اشعار اخر
اذا عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
الزلزال المدمر الذي هز سوريا وتركيا دفع
بدول عده لتنحيه حسابات وعقوبات واعطاء
الاولويه للاغاثه والمساعده الانسانيه رفع
العقوبات الامريكيه عن سوريا مدته 180
يوما اما جيران تركيا فهبوا للمساعده رغم
توتر علاقات نتابع دبلوماسيه الكوارث لم
تصطدم بخرسانات متهاويه لكنها تخطتها
لترفع جدران عزله احاطت بالنظام السوري
لسنوات واعادت خلط اوراق الرئيس التركي
السياسيه
زلزال السادس من فبراير حل مدمرا قتل وفرق
وشرد لكنه اسقط حواجز وخلافات سياسيه
هيمنه على علاقات دول لحين لملمت الماساه
فازاح الدول لا ترتبط بعلاقات طيبه مع
تركيا او سوريا ملفاتها موضع الخلاف
وانضمت الى قافله المساعدين واشنطن
استعانت باستثناءات خاصه بالعمليات
الانسانيه لتعلق العقوبات المفروضه على
سوريا وتسمح بادخال المساعدات اليها
وفي وقت ارسلت فرق انقاذ لتركيا اكتفت
بتقديم المساعده لسوريا عبر شركاء محليين
لرفضها التعامل مع الاسد اما في تركيا
فانفتح الطاقات التعاون من مختلف الجهات
فالحدود مع ارمينيا فتحت لاول مره منذ
عقود لادخال المساعدات رغم خلافات تاريخيه
الجار اليوناني تخطط توترات كادت ان تصل
لمواجهه عسكريه بسبب نزاعات على جزر
وتنقيب عن مصادر الطاقه دبلوماسيه الزلزال
شملت زياره لوزير الخارجيه اليوناني برفقه
نظيره التركي الى انطاكيا وارسال مساعدات
انسانيه وفرق اغاثه وعمال انقاذ لتحقق ما
قاله السفير التركي السابق لدى اثنا
بخطابه الوداعي تمنيات بعدم الحاجه لكوارث
او زلازل لتذكر الجيره
السويد تناست موقف تركيا المعرقله لمسع
انضمامها لحلف شمال الاطلسي فطور
والعلاقات لم يؤخر مصر كذلك عن ارسال
مساعدات طبيه الى تركيا كما لم تؤثر
العمليات العسكريه التركيه شمال العراق في
تضمين انقره بالجسر الجوي الاغاثي
[موسيقى]
الوضع هنا صعب للغايه امي واختي ما زالتا
تحت الانقاض ولا استطيع الوصول اليهما باي
شكل من الاشكال انهما تموتان تحت الانقاض
وانا اموت هنا
[موسيقى]
لقد تلاشت امال الان املوا فقط ان يخرجوا
من هنا لا احد يساعد لا اتوقع اي شيء من
الحكومه بعد الان
[موسيقى]
صالوصل معكم تغطتنا للزلزال لمشاهدينا لكن
نتوقف مع بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات اخرى
قالت صحيفه الجارد البريطانيه ان طهران
تستخدم قوارب وشريكه طيران مملوكه للدوله
لتهريب المسيرات الى روسيا واوضحت الصحيفه
ان ايران سلمت 18 مسيره بعيده المدى
للبحريه الروسيه مشيره الى ان الوفد
الروسي الذي زار طهران في نوفمبر الماضي
طلب سته مسيرات محمله بالصواريخ وان هذه
المسيرات كانت تصنع في المنشاه التي تم
استهدافها في اصفهان الشهر الماضي
كشف الرئيس البولندي اندريدا ان عدد
القوات الامريكيه التي تم نشرها في بلاده
تضاعف خلال العامين الماضيين ووصل الى
عشره الاف جندي الرئيس البولندي قال ايضا
ان بلاده فعلت كل شيء من اجل الانضمام الى
الناتو مع تعزيز الحلفيت وجوده في الجناح
الشرقي
اعلنت المتحدثه باسم حلف الناتو
[موسيقى]
لا يرغب في تمديد جديد لولايته بعد
انتهائها في اكتوبر وكان قاده دول الحلف
قد قرروا في مارس الماضي تمديد مهمه
بعد اندلاع الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه عنف المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين مؤكده ضروره وقف هجماتهم
وقالت البعثه عبر حسابها على تويتر انها
تشعر بقلق من تزايد عدد الهجمات واحذرت من
انف المستوطنين سيؤججوا الوضع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
انطلقت حشود كبيره قدرت بعشرات الالاف من
الايرانيين المقيمين في فرنسا في مظاهره
ومسيره حاشده وسط العاصمه باريس حيث حملوا
صورا لمن تم اعدامهم ورددوا شعارات داعمه
للاحتجاجات في ايران كما دعوا الاتحاد
الاوروبي لتصنيف حرس النظام منظمه ارهابيه
في السودان يستمر الخلاف حول القوه التي
يحق لها التوقيع على الاتفاق الايطالي
الجديد وقال القيادي في تحالف الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي شهاب ابراهيم
الطيب ان النقاش يتعلق بضم حركه العدل
والمساواه وحركه تحرير السودان والحزب
الديمقراطي الاتحادي الديمقراطي للاتفاق
وسط توتر بين واشنطن وبيكين اعلن الاسطول
السابع الامريكي المتمركز في اليابان ان
مجموعه القوه الضاربه لحامله الطائرات
uss والوحده الاستكشافيه البحريه الثالثه
عشره قماني بعمليات استكشافيه متكامله في
بحر الصين الجنوبي
[موسيقى]